all right silver summit health plan the
sponsors for this next segment is
hosting a pop-up farmers market and
community health fair here to talk about
that we have janie root from just one
project also is casey flair janie you
are from silver summer yes casey janie
thank you so much for being here let's
talk about this health fair it sounds
like it's going to be a blast super
excited um we're we're here with the
just one project it's to actually launch
our partnership with the just one
project silver summit health plan feels
like it's we want to give back to our
community and one of our
partners in the community is the just
one project and i'm going to let casey
talk a little bit more about the pop-up
farmers market but just this is going to
be our launch and this event is going to
be on saturday it's going to be a fun
time for everyone um
besides having the food we're going to
have a health fair there will be
screenings dental vision
medical screenings they can get
immunizations there is all kind of
community resources for them a fun time
for the kids
we have bike giveaways laptop computers
gift cards
caricature artists and they're going to
do airbrushing on t-shirts and hats so i
mean it's going to be a fun time for the
whole entire family this is on saturday
it is such a
sounds like such a great event and for
such a good cause casey we've talked to
you before about the just one project
but for those who aren't familiar with
it what do you guys do absolutely i just
want to say thank you to silver summit
for really just being a pillar in our
community and being able to give back i
think that's huge and for the
partnership with the just one project
and what we're able to do really with
this with this farmers market we'll talk
a little bit more about but the just one
project is nevada's largest mobile food
pantry we serve over 20 000 clients
uh every single month so just last year
almost 300 000 clients it's a it's a
huge
a huge need in our community and with
partners like silver summit we're able
to serve them the pop-up farmers market
is really something that uh it's really
cool it's one of our newer programs it's
the ability for our community and our
clients to come shop at a farmers market
for no cost produce we're gonna have
produce vegetables um
recipe cards to go with those so we'll
have the zucchinis we'll have the
avocados we'll have the oranges we'll
have the watermelons
so it should be a really really cool
event and we're just excited that silver
summit sees the value and what we're
doing for our community and being able
to be a part of it we love it casey
janey thank you so much for being here
today really appreciate it and let's
tell people again farmers market and
community health fair is happening this
saturday from 3 until 7 pm at the
paradise recreation center you can get
more information by calling that number
on the screen
702-455-7513 there will be free fruits
and vegetables from the farmers market
and that's while supplies last mercedes